look at Pascal's triangle we're gonna be
using Pascal's triangle and expanding
these binomials so if you look over here
you can see the pattern with Pascal's
triangle is that it starts with 1 ok and
then each row starts with 1 and ends
with 1 and the way that we get these
terms each successive row is what we do
is we add the two terms above like so 1
plus 1 is 2 we want to get this term
here we add the two terms above 1 plus 2
is 3 and so on 3 plus 3 is 6 so it
always starts with 1 and ends with 1 and
you can keep going this will keep
expanding out in K Pascal's triangle and
where these terms actually come from is
from the combinations and you can see
here that like in this row out of this
fifth row I've got 5 choose 0 okay 5
choose 1 5 choose 2 5 choose 3 5 choose
4 or 5 choose 5 now if you're not not
familiar with the combinations it's like
saying if you had you know like a hat
and you reached into the hat there's
five items how many ways are there to
choose two items say for example for
this one okay where the order is not
important like you could pick a and B or
B an a that's the same you know choice
and there would be ten different ways to
choose two items out of those five so
there's a formula here for the
combinations it's NCR equals n factorial
divided by n minus R factorial R
factorial okay and again if you need a
review on what the factorials are
factorial you just start off like see
here five factorial you start off at
that number and you multiply down to one
so it'd be like 5 times 4 times 3 times
2 times 1 okay so in this case that's
going to be 120 so a little bit of an
overview here with Pascal's triangle let
me show you an example how this works so
say we want to expand X plus 2 to the
fourth power okay one option is we can
go down to the fourth row of Pascal's
triangle ok by the way that starts at
row zero and then it goes Row 1 Row 2
Row 3 Row 4 so we're going to look at
this row here these are going to be our
coefficients okay so I'm going to write
this out as 1
four six four and one and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take this
first term take as a binomials two terms
going to take the first term to the
highest power here so that's going to be
X to the fourth x cubed x squared X to
the first X to the zero so that first
term you can see we're going in
descending order then what we're going
to do is we're going to take the second
term okay and we're gonna go in
ascending order so that's going to be
like this two to the 0 2 to the first
two to the second 2 to the third 2 to
the fourth and in between all these
terms we're just going to have a pot a
plus sign okay so let's just go back and
simplify this and so you can see
anything to the 0 power is 1 times 1
gives us X to the 4th 2 to the first
times 4 is 8 so that gives us 8 X cubed
2 squared is 4 times 6 is 24 right 2
cubed is 8 times 4 is 32 and X to the 0
is 1 times 1 is 1 times 2 to the fourth
is 16 and this is our expansion of X
plus 2 to the fourth now just to kind of
recap here another way to do this of
course is to write x plus 2 times X plus
2 times X plus 2 C four times and go
ahead and you know distribute or do the
foil method and work through all those
and expand it out combine like terms but
you're gonna find that this is a lot
faster especially as this power goes you
know up and up and up so let's take a
look at another example here we've got
expand 2x minus 3y to the fifth power so
here we're gonna go down to the fifth
row okay
now if you don't want to do Pascal's
triangle you could always just use the
combinations you could say this is 5 - 0
5 choose 1 those are going to be our
coefficients you can use this formula or
you can use your calculator that has
combinations on it to calculate these
values but let's go ahead and use
Pascal's triangle since we have it here
so what we have is 1 5 10
10 5 and I'm running out of space I'm
going to put this one down here one okay
we're going to take that first term 2x
we're going to raise that to the fifth
power and we're gonna go in descending
order
okay so 2x cubed 2x squared 2x to the
first and 2x to the 0 okay and we're
going to take the second term I'm going
to take this whole thing negative 3y and
we're going to go in ascending order so
we're going to go to the 0th power and
then we're to go up from there so this
is going to be negative 3y to the first
power this is going to be negative 3y to
the second power and notice there's just
an addition sign in between all these
terms negative 3y to the third negative
3y to the fourth and negative 3y to the
fifth and these are just all added
together now we're gonna go back and
were going to simplify so 2 to the fifth
is 32 okay
anything to 0 power is 1 so this first
term is going to give us 32 X to the
fifth okay the next term is 2 to the
fourth was just 16 K times 5 is 80 times
negative 3 is negative 240 X to the
fourth Y to the first we go to the next
term we've got 2 cubed which is 8
negative 3 squared is 9 8 times 9 is 72
times 10 is 720 so we have 720 X cubed Y
squared okay keep going here so 2
squared is 4 negative 3 cubed is
negative 27 so that's how much let's see
negative 54 negative 108 times 10 that
would be negative 1080 you can coerce
use a calculator to do these
calculations I'm just doing them in my
head here negative 3 to the 4th is 81
okay times 2 is 160 2 times 5 is how
much or we'll do the calculator so this
is 5 times 2 is 10 times 81 is 810 right
so that's going to give you 810 X Y to
the fourth K plus negative three to the
fifth is a negative 243 anything
powers one so for our last term we get
negative 243 so we fully expanded that